mais je pense qu il faut qu'on reste
français dans ce qu'on a de mieux en
nous il faut arrêter de jouer avec le
feu voilà c'est marine le pen fait une
campagne exceptionnelle et elle a trouvé
le curseur pour se mettre au niveau des
français mais après faut pas oublier
alain prénom c'est marine elle
capitalise là dessus mais elle a un nom
de famille et c'est le pen et pour toute
personne qui a comme toi et moi le même
cuir chevelu
nos jours sont comptés ne dis pas ça
devant mort par les cheveux le premier
en easyjet
plus sérieusement je pense qu'on peut on
peut ne pas être d'accord mais voilà
enfin je pense que le meilleur slogan
s'est fâché mais pas facho moi j saab
mais on peut être en colère contre ce
président peut visiblement l'interpellé
comme si c'était un mec qui fait du
stand up puisque
c'est pas ça me choque mais je pense que
si on commence à désacraliser
il se mettre et se dire que le président
en fait c'est monsieur tout le monde il
faut pas être en fait choqué par le
genre de propos qu'on entend toute la
journée sur nos médias ce monsieur est
peut être en colère mais si notre
président il incarne quand même quelque
chose même si les gens n'ont pas voté
pour lui c'est quand même quelqu'un qui
va aller parler à poutine c'est
quelqu'un qui va voyager dans le monde
rapaille est en panne yassine est né en
campanie va au devant
mais c'est valable pour tous les
candidats manger autant choqué de voir
qu'on s'en prend à des candidats mais
juste lui c'est le président
actuellement et que je pense qu'il faut
pas commencer sinon c'est la foire à
l'empoigné mais juste pour revenir là
dessus je moi je jamais je mettrais un
bulletin le pen il faut arrêter
objectivement notre pays ne va pas bien
il faut reconstruire quelque chose
ensemble et on est on est face à face en
ce moment alors qu'on devrait être côte
à côte et objectivement je dis ça moi
quand je mets le bulletin c'est
l'histoire de mes parents que je mets
aussi et je vais pas attendre que moi
mes parents alors que toute leur vie ils
ont baissé leur tête parce que c'était
des gens issus de l'immigration sont
travailler dur pour choix devant vous et
que je parle couramment le français que
j'ai une bonne et du kasaï on parle bien
et qu'en fait à la faille découvre moi
mes parents viennent d'être à la
retraite je vais pas leur faire le
cadeau de passer leur retraite
dorénavant avec le pen et puis surtout
je ne sais pas ce qu'en pense que j'ai
écouté son propos mais les amis il ya
des décrets c'est à dire que même si
elle n'a pas la majorité à l'assemblée
elle va gouverner sous décret et si du
jour au lendemain cette femme se
réveillent et commencent à dire les
musulmans ça soit au fond du bus vous
n'aurez aucun moyen autour de cette
table pour arrêter ça il faut arrêter de
dire que le pen c'est normal le pen
c'est pas normal le pen c'est un parti
qui a été créée avec des nazis c'est
l'histoire de ce pays faut arrêter de
dire que jean moulin et le pen c'est la
même chose je dis pas que macro a fait
un bon mandat loin de là je suis de
confession musulmane croyez moi j'ai
vécu pour le coup un mandat avec
schiappa darmanin et blanc caire qui
était hors sol jamais on n'a autant
parlé de l'islam et autant de ministres
pour le coup un peu un peu amateur ont
surfé sur cette vague là et le en même
temps ça marche pour tous sauf sur le
respect des gens jean luc mélenchon il a
fait une croix pabx exceptionnel juste
en nous rappelant qu'ils avaient des
français de confession musulmane il n'a
pas dit pour le voile contre il a juste
dit à un moment il faut reconnaître le
talent de jean luc mélenchon est
franchement moi je salue les électeurs
de jean luc mélenchon qui sont très
énervés contre le président mais pas au
point de 0,20 avec le pen au pouvoir
personne ne sortira grandi et on aura
une interrogation et je te le dis
franchement pas ce qu'on a dit lançant
bien deux jours on aura une
responsabilité éditoriale toi moi tous
autour de cette table on a laissé des
gens parler sur les plateaux qui sont
des fous furieux qu'on a suivi à la
trace qui ont fait des sorties qui sont
venus sur nos plateaux ça faisait de
l'audience certes mais à quel prix moi
je me suis mangé des scuds durant ce
quinquennat sur les plateaux j'étais
entre des ch et kaboul alors que je suis
n'a conflans sainte honorine mais j'ai
toujours été français et ça c'est
quelque chose qui choque et je vais te
dire quelque chose aujourd'hui je
reviens du maroc qui ont fait il ya
quelques jours au maroc qui regardent
les chaînes françaises et les marocains
et 10 mais qu'est ce qui se passe dans
ce pays où ce que vous regardez vos
chaînes de télé qu'est ce qui se passe
dans votre pays donc c'est pour ça que
je dis moi je suis en accord et
visiblement manière myriam comme
division vous avez été vécu un
confinement assez compliqué mais on se
connaît pas mais je vous dire quelque
chose j'ai été très touché par
l'argument de vos enfants mais n'oubliez
pas quelque chose là vous êtes filmés et
si c'est pour dans dix ans montrent des
images de vous en train de dire sur un
plateau télé je vois que le pen je crois
pas que vos enfants ils seront heureux
je vous le dis
moi moi je respecte monsieur monsieur
belattar et jeu et je vous le dis
honnêtement vous êtes dans votre combat
et je le respecte grandement mais votre
combat n'est pas le mien vraiment vous
pour vous
marine le pen est extrême parce que
votre combat c'est la religion moi moi
moi moi c'est pas la religion en tout
cas c'est pas vous avez dit tout à
l'heure que les musulmans serait au fond
moi j'ai rien contre les musulmans qui
peut porter le voir ça franchement je
m'en fous mais totalement mais moi pour
moi c'est monsieur m'a compris et
extrême parce que mon combat c'est la
liberté est aujourd'hui pendant trente
ans on nous a dit l'extrême droite c'est
ceci c'est cela c'est tout ce que
voulait moi je ne vote pas pour marine
le pen par conviction par contre je vote
contre ma contre monsieur macron par
conviction je suis désolé si marine le
pen aujourd'hui hélas ce n'est pas moi
qui ai fait d'elle ce qu'elle est
aujourd'hui salle et les les politiques
c'est eux qui ont fait de marine le pen
aujourd'hui monsieur mâcon il est très
content d'avoir marine le pen en face de
lui parce que il se prononce en dix ans
la diabolisant - aujourd'hui ce serait
monsieur mélenchon qui serait face à
monsieur macro je voterai monsieur
mélenchon se serait monsieur la salle
qinglin à luna se serait monsieur la
salle qui serait face à emmanuel fac
roma coup je voterai pour emmanuel
macron ce serait marrant non non
ce serait monsieur dupont-aignan qui
serait de face à emmanuel macron je
voterai contre
quelqu'un je vote pour la liberté de moi
de pouvoir faire de mon corps ce que je
veux me réveiller un même show non mais
mirabeau voc la même si non mais moi je
fais pas la même chose je vous dis juste
moi l'extrême droite c'est non alors il
ya des gens qui n'en attendait que
jusqu'au bout mais moi j'ai des
désaccords présent avec géraldine des
choses sur lesquelles on n'est pas
d'accord à vous aussi
je pense enfin tu me coupe si j'ai tort
qui à un moment il ya une frontière
qu'on ne dépasse pas ensemble vraiment
je pense qu'il ya 6 et moi on vous voyez
je suis français dans l'intégralité de
marque française des jeux ce n est pas
la préfecture comme c'est bien beau
mais juste pour vous dire quelque chose
un moment il y avait un homme d'état qui
s'appelait jacques chirac et jacques
chirac moi il m'a vexé avec le bruit et
l'odeur qui a été quelque chose pour
nous qui était très bas si tu peux nous
rappeler ça c'est le bruit et l'odeur
c'est que jacques chirac il a fait une
interview à jour après être passés à
table je crois qu'il est à 8 g il a dit
il a parlé des femmes issues de
l'immigration sur le palier et il y
avait du bruit et de l'odeur c'est
d'ailleurs un morceau formidable d'un
groupe que j'aime beaucoup qui s'appelle
zebda et qui avait montré un côté de
chirac qui était néanmoins pour le coup
pas surprenant mais il y avait cette
droite gaulliste qui s'estiment c'est
qu'on ne parle pas avec l'extrême droite
n'ont rien mis en vedette des gens qui
disent tu vois beaucoup de gens disent
elle préfère juste avoir le pen comme
présidente juste pour pas que ma qu'on
repasse faut rester cinq minutes c'est
juste la raison qui doit ravir à
turbenthal film mais en fait yacine je
pense que tu restes sur quelque chose
d'avant quand tu dis ok c'est marine
mais elle s'appelle le pen attention ce
n'est pas son père comme toi tu es pas
tes parents en fait on n'est pas pareil
et c'est bien pour ça qu'elle a un peu
coupé avec son père parce que lui
c'était lui elle sait quelque chose
d'autre tu vois que quand tu la regardes
que quand tu l'écoutent elle propose
vraiment quelque chose elle a travaillé
elle a une forme de bienveillance
elle a une forme de bienveillance on a
coutume mais
là elle est en train de me faire une
macro et aucune liste donc les trucs je
te dirai sont aujourd'hui elle est
aujourd'hui ont le droit de voter qu'il
a fauté mais absolument aux jeunes à
droite quelqu'un d'autre qu emmanuel
macron qui a fait son temps puisqu'il a
fait cinq ans il avait 5 ans pour nous
montrer ce qui pouvait faire aujourd'hui
à la sortie le bilan c'est que plus de
60% des français ne veulent pas
reconduire et pourtant les gens n'osent
pas parce qu'il y a des gens comme toi
qui disent surtout pas l'extrait moi
c'est ce que vous et moi je sais ce que
vous dites on attribue le rassemblement
national elle a bien changé parce que
tout le monde peut évoluer juste donc
j'étais fait que ce que vous dit
d'attendre que tu dis que la tribune des
sportifs qu'ils ont fait aujourd'hui
taupin de sortie qui ont dit tout sauf
marine le pen moi ça tu réponds à sa rue
neuve cambrésis une présidente famelart
voilà une une présidente femme
j'aimerais bien voilà une maman des
français quelqu'un qui rassemble qui
protège avec une sensibilité de femme on
sait très bien que les hommes il parle
beaucoup ils font pas tout le temps on
sait bien que les femmes c'est des
mamans c'est une maman qui fait des
choses et les femmes on peut les femmes
les femmes elle arrive enfin mais si
tu as été miss france oui parce que moi
aussi en aurait accepté l'idée que la
miss france représente une partie des
français et c'est à dire ne tourne le
dos aux autres moi je pense que tu dois
comprendre qu' on est un pays qui n'est
pas en accord
c'est pas grave jusqu'à présent le
faisait dans un territoire qui était
pour le coup respectueux je te dis juste
je vous dis on sent qu'ils veulent voter
extrême droite y a des gens qui votent
extrême - je te le dis juste amicalement
parce qu'on se connaît tu ne peux pas
dire à des gens que marine le pen c'est
la mère de la france est à dire à des
gens que marine le pen c'est le diable
je n'ai pas dit ça variable parce que je
te dis mais tu es en train de donner je
te le dis pourri gens le droit des gens
aujourd'hui ils profitent de ce no man's
land en ce moment pour se dire l'extrême
droite c'est norman ans yacine ttc mais
alors si je rate delphine aussi
voir marine le pen à des chats
sévriens dit qu'ils allaient amener à
nous battre il aime la nature moi ça va
j'ai les miennes alors je te rappelles
toi même tu auras plus progresser chez
des chats
d'abord moi je respectais ses
convictions et ce sont ces convictions
mais aussi de tout et yacine yacine tu
es en train de nous faire une laurent
fontaine c'est une insulte à lens
sans nenê tu donnes ont encore des
arguments qui date d'il ya 20 ans oui
les gens m'ont bien 2010 7,1 me disent
on a pleins d'espoir en emmanuel macron
est aujourd'hui qu'est ce qu'ils veulent
les gens me connaissent qu'ils veulent
les gens mais attends ils ne veulent
plus macro mais ils veulent vibrer
l'oreille est arrivé largement en tête
au premier tour en anglais il est arrivé
dans le temps mais
j'ai un moment donné il faut parler de
son programme il faut argumenter vous
n'êtes pas passer votre temps de le
préparer juste dire aux gens qu'ils ont
désespéré ne votez pas marine le pen ne
marche ni c'est pas comme ça qu'on est
rien juste quelques questions nicolas
pernikoff comment tu t'appelles
pernikoff nom votre prénom
nicolas de là donc je peux te dire quand
tu t'appelles nicolas il ya des français
qui s'appelle nicolas qui sont affectées
par l'arrivée de l'open mais je peux te
dire que tous ceux qui n'ont pas un
prénom à consonance comme la tienne voir
le pen au pouvoir ça les ramène au fait
d'être éliminé de son nom des gens
qu'aujourd'hui tu reviens là je regarde
les gens si je peux me permettre un
suspect congrès il s'appelle jean marc
coude
non mais attends un moment donné il faut
quand même être après moi j'ai pas les
idées de marine le pen mais il faut
quand même rappeler qu'on est parfois
cambrai la défense centrale est en train
de mais ce n'est pas comme ça qu'on fera
passer emmanuel macron si tu veux faire
passer mais je manage our man il faut
juste mais justement américaine hillary
l'accent sur le comptoir mois qu est ce
qui me désole moi ce qui le désole un
programme qui est un simple câble ce qui
me plaît ce qui me désole quand les mecs
c'est qu'on soit ou compass régional de
seulement de celui pour qui on va pas
voter d'avril
emmanuel macron avait promis le vote
blanc il ya cinq ans il est où le vote
blanc jeu désolé ça la route mais marine
le pen soit en face de lui parce qu'il
l'a diabolisé mais pourquoi il n'a pas
mis le vote blanc non mais c'est vrai ça
parle robles j'aurais pas et 10 q ces
gens moi j'aime beaucoup j'aime beaucoup
le fait franchement je vous le dis
j'aime beaucoup le fait qu'on dise j'ai
mis un slip sur
les gens ils veulent gagner en pouvoir
d'achat c'est l'urgence aujourd'hui la
france dans tout paris mais marc le plus
tôt par pitau du fait de 2,2 d'annuler
la tva par exemple sur des produits de
première nécessité
sinon ça va mais parle de ça plutôt des
faits si tu dis juste dervaux pas voter
pour marine le btan une rame tu veux tu
qu'elle défend une race et mais les
français ne pense pas qu'elle ait ghazi
maison
royale
[Rires]
mais est-ce que delphine pense que
marine le pen est raciste rabat un nom
mais bon programme
2 les deux candidats yassine sont
légitimes et je vais te dire moi en 2012
j'ai voté pour madame pourquoi parce que
c'était une nouvelle personne choisie
mais j'aimerais bien essayer la france
pendant cinq ans avec une nouvelle
personne mais là j'ai vu ce qu'il a fait
et ça ne m'a pas
cru et moi je vais vous dire un truc ce
que j'aime vraiment avoir la faune bref
moi chaque soir je regarde le public de
tvnp je suis fier de ce public non mais
ça rigolait regardez c'est un truc de
faire et ils sont tous s'entendent ils
sont tous laïcs qui font passer un bon
moment il se pose pas la question de qui
est musulman qui pourra faire des
sondages encore mais c'est vrai pour
être là nous ce qu'on le truc c'est
qu'on a tous peur d'une france visés oui
c'est vrai il ya sid ali
yassine et moi on est bon on s'adore
voilà on s'aime on sait ont l'art et
c'est vrai et jamais on sait plus on
fait on fait nos trucs qu'on fait note
d'hier c'est très bien quand on a des
potes ses rivaux des red est pote avec
l'eau leur demande pas s'ils sont
musulmans ont fait je me sens
moi je reconnais à talons à marine le
pen il faut dire la vérité elle a fait
une campagne exceptionnelle année mais
je vous dis la vérité oui elle l'a fait
elle est en train de mourir et les
français contre les uns contre les
autres c'est lisible messier touche
finale estimé myriam je finis juste une
seule défaite à l'heure mais excuse moi
et je suis en train de parler non merci
le respect le respect a fracturé la main
mais je finirai homme qui séparait la
fête aux orres myriam oui mais oui mais
alors voyons ce qui va se passer mais en
suède mais vous vous parliez tout à
l'heure vous disais delphine parce que
tu ne te sens pas concerné mais vous on
peut vous reprocher la même chose vous
ne vous êtes pas sentis concernés comme
et 10 millions de français qui ont été
mis qui ont été privés de leur vie de
couple
sur sept ans de suite et je me sens bien
ça c'est pas la liberté je suis désolé
je suis je suis désolé monsieur mais
pendant que ceux ci n'ont jamais été
aussi mis mal à mal que je
suis désolé de vous dire sens mais
aujourd'hui il n'a pas respecté
l'assemblée nationale il n'a pas
respecté le sénat qu'est ce que vous
voulez vous voulez parler de démocratie
non mais myriam déjà
[Applaudissements]
alors moi j'ai dit à mes rien mais hier
ce que je pensais de sont tout sauf
macron c'est pour moi extrêmement
dangereux et je comprends pas votre
engagement totalement militant j'ai dit
presque illuminait après vous répondra
yacine mais voilà j'ai dit la même chose
que vous c'est à dire que vous dites à
lire à six mois j'ai dit ici sur ce
plateau son parti raciste et je pense
mon cheikh yassine que nous avons tort
de dire ça je vais vous expliquer comme
je pense que la tribune des sportifs
elle est ridicule ce que je pense
qu'aujourd'hui les gens ne peuvent pas
ils ne veulent pas entendre ça et je
vous le dit les yeux dans les yeux parce
que j'ai dit la même chose que vous les
gens nous aiment beaucoup je pense
qu'aujourd'hui il faut expliquer il faut
comprendre le malaise des gens le mal
être il faut comprendre qu'ils n'ont pas
d'argent qu'ils ne peuvent pas joindre
les deux bouts alors la tentation de
voter pour marine le pen il faut pas la
diaboliser le
chili juste fini j'ai donc je pense que
je comprends tout à fait votre
engagement mais je pense que c'est
presque ont fait vous et moi contre
produits de l'armée je vous dira que
marine sur rien les limites par le pen
sur le fait d'être raciste je vous dis
juste que si aujourd'hui jean-luc
mélenchon a draftés 70% de l'électorat
musulman c'est pas un petit chiffre
c'est à dire que même des musulmans qui
ont une situation financière très
favorables ont décidé économiquement de
voter contre eux parce que juste on leur
a donné du respect juste pour aller ou
la sage et 30 % seraient prêts à voter
pour marine le pen mais non juste un
message sans le dire aussi alors comment
vérité c'est une question de religion et
dessine nicolas moi je te dis la vérité
il faut arrêter de se faire des formes
ans vous vaillant citoyens on se connaît
je te dis la vérité nicolas je t'aime
beaucoup mais tu me regarde droit dans
les yeux et tu me suis dit attends je te
fini ma phrase que tu me dise droit dans
les yeux marine le pen c'est
envisageable je te dis la vérité ni à la
raison et à la passion pardon de le dire
ça pour myriam ou division où toutes les
bêtes que vous allez créer sur ce
plateau c'est quand même à venir on
passe
alors il assis là c'est bien sinon si
l'on reçoit tu montes sur des bêtes
médiatique mais je m
bête médiatique je vais au bout je vais
oublier je n'ai rien à gagner tous âges
et ça va pas la tête
non mais attendez vous passez votre vie
sur l'image que tu donnes n'allait pas
bonne yacine parquet mais attendez su
s'intégrer s'il en est est ce que tu as
cru que ta condescendance en et non pas
du tout mais je t'explique l'autre une
coupe la parole bon alors je suis rentré
au doigt alors venez pas où on va où
maintenant aujourd'hui la discussion
c'est de dire vous passez votre temps
sur les plateaux à nous expliquer
d'accord sur le co vide je suis mille
fois d'accord moi je fais des spectacles
d'accord je fais des tournées en france
évidemment quand je vois des gens qui ne
se sont pas vaccinés ne pas avoir accès
à mon spectacle est de voir à quel point
ça les affecte ça m'a fait aussi ses
qualifications non mais attendez dit pas
ça
est-ce que c'est le mot ségrégation est
ce que vous savez le poids des mots oui
parce que vous savez non mais non mais
je suis méchant mais attendez je n'avais
cyril je te le dis mais n'est ce pas un
mot comme ça passe et n'a même pas de
ségrégation des noirs américains en
afrique du sud des pays bas des gens
s'il a
voulu dire discrimination
lisation
discrétion va pas s'arrêter sur un mot
mejia palomba vouliez dire quoi moi je
vous parlais tout à l'heure mais excusez
moi monsieur jean michel blanquer s'est
prononcé contre le voile mais alors pas
raciste monsieur macron avait 7 50% tous
les visas marocains et algériens ça même
créé une crise diplomatique
c'est pas raciste mais moi j'en le
programme de monsieur macron il veut que
pour les gens qui faisaient la
nationalité française il parle français
et le couscous au japon par geoffrey
soupe je vous dit je vous dis simplement
à les voir les migrants qui sont à
calais et que tu meures m'a parlé de
schiphol ni ni ni commence à faire une
leçon au travail comment ils font pour
parler français qu'est ce qui est plus
rare sens pas de bordeaux je suis désolé
là je vais vous dire un truc moi tout à
l'heure il ya un signe parler de bête
médiatique ici on crée pas des bêtes
médiatique on donne la parole à tout et
on l'a vu au heureusement qu'on a donné
la parole à tout le monde dans cette
émission et heureusement qu'il ya eu un
lieu de débat comme dans tpm pays parce
que sinon c'est lui ce serait bien si on
dira que c'est lui non mais je dis pas
ce que je te dis frank gehry
amoureusement contre de navarre ont
aussi parce que elle
elle a donné elle représentait aussi pas
mal de français qui ont même avis quel
nom mais beaucoup de réactions motonari
le sterne à un moment il ya des pays qui
ont fait d'eux le choix de la réaction
le brésil en angleterre et brésil et
l'angleterre ça va très bien non mais
attends ils sont patients mais je tenais
bien sûr le père ça va travailler ça va
beaucoup mieux que l'allemagne non mais
a fait le choix de l'allemagne et qui
sont dans une misère noire là en ce
moment je te dire je suis pas en train
de te dire je vais voter aveuglément
pour emmanuel macron je te dis juste
qu'un moment j'aimerais que le débat se
fasse dans un espace bien sûr serein et
juste un moment je ne comprends pas
l'idée depuis tout à l'heure que le fait
de dire que quelqu'un qui a prêché la
différence et qui dit je vais mettre une
amende aux femmes voilées donc un moment
je me dis c'est super beau de dire
myriam la liberté la liberté mais les
gens et on les renvoie la liberté on a
mis des amendes à des gens qui avaient
le drapeau français monsieur nommé bah
oui je vous le demande et ça fait pas
lemoine y aura des amendements mollet
non mais je suis pas d'accord avec ça je
suis pas d'accord avec vous mais vous
avez vous ne l'avez résoudre m'étais
jamais donc non mais dans tous les
programmes et les trucs qui vous pas
bien vrai
par exemple moi ça me dérange tellement
en fait c'est quoi le monde y agir en
fait ben tiens c'est ce qu'il a c'est ça
qui est grave c'est que des médias on va
voter pour le moins pire et c'est un
tout
c'est son nom mais c'est surtout la
réaction pour te dire géraldine l'idée
de dire j'en veux à macron c'est
possible je le reconnais la séquence
vous avez montré c'est quand même la
preuve qu' il ya des reproches mais le
fait d'en arriver au point de se dire et
basse schulz a au nom c'est à dire qu'il
n'ya plus d'étapes non pardon c'est en
effet de mâcon kamil cadre non mais des
amis que savez ce que c'est ce que tu as
au nom mais c'est donc je vais tester
autre chose c'est tout simplement chez
flunch
division m'a tuer le premier qui fait
que de parler en fonction du prisme de
la religion est ce que moi je parle du
président la religion là je tenais juste
il ya trois religions monothéistes dans
ce pays et on a même plus il ya des
juifs il ya des musulmans il ya des
chrétiens ils veulent qu'on les laisse
tranquilles il y en a ils croient pas en
dieu on les laisse tranquilles de la
même manière on est affecté de la même
manière autour de cette table quand il
ya un attentat qui touche enjeux qui
touchent charlie hebdo quand il ya un
attentat qui touche une école avec des
enfants juifs quand aujourd'hui il ya
encore une femme a montpellier on lui
retire le voile on l'a tabassé des
images abominables parce que ce que vous
ne comprenez pas c'est qu'il va y avoir
un troisième tour et qui a des gens
aujourd'hui qu'ils sont racistes dans ce
pays qui veulent jouer l'élection dans
la rue et on n'en voit pas comme comme
signaux c'est que dorénavant toute
personne qui est élue elle est légitime
mais les amis des seuls endroits on est
légitime à 100% c'est les dictatures
africaines ou en amérique du sud c'est
le président d'une démocratie
heureusement à une opposition et moi je
vous dis sur matheron parce que pour
vous montrez moi je suis lui souhaite au
prochain mandat d'avoir une opposition
de qualité mais je pense objectivement
que les offres soumises qui sont des
gens qui ont fait un travail formidable
vont tenir la dragée haute à emmanuel
macro je souhaite que les républicains
se construisent pas ce que vous voulez
pas le voir mais tous ceux qui ont mis
le doigt dans le grand remplacement dix
ans les français ne s'aiment pas ils ont
fait moins 10% dans ce pays parce
qu'aujourd'hui les gens comme la gauche
qui se disait paris décide et la
province on s'en fout ils ont fait moins
5% à l'objective mans aujourd'hui marine
le pen son génie son génie contrairement
à son père c'est de faire croire que le
changement c'est elle le changement
c'est pas l égout la main sur des objets
on va arrêter jeu du sujet clôture moi
je voulais poser une question à la norme
et non pas question de culture il
n'avait il m'a choqué quand il a dit
qu'on avait créé des monstres ici bien
sûr que des myriades des dix vidéos là
tu m'as tu as janvier j'ai pas des
monstres j'ai dit
ok mais alors non mais on ne peut pas
museler des opinions des jeunes avant
libéral nouvelles conditions je veux
dire il faut les fumer non là je suis né
j'ai eu l'impression que tu disais il
faut les faire taire on aurait mieux les
invités n'ont pas droit tenant les
attends je trouve que c'est hyper
dangereux parce que ça c'est un l'on
verra des robots c'est une manière de
faire taire les oppositions te dit je
veux surtout tout le monde puisque les
médias semblent c'est pas ça le problème
tu veux exprimer tout le monde a le
droit vida bon j'ai pas dit ça je te dis
vous avez créé des bêtes médiatique non
pas des monstres faire attention à ce
que je dis pas non déçu et objectivement
et jacky pas sûr sur les bateaux je te
dis la vérité devienne des mégastars au
dessus de vous parce qu'en fait ils ont
trouvé la cadence il vient ni senti
vaccine ya pas de soucis quand ils sont
plus anti vaccins ils disent les
libertés on les a peints et d'un coup
pour qu'on les réinvite à chaque fois
que le pen non ça sera non je suis à
vous mais là vous dit des choses sur moi
qui sont totalement fausses et si vous
me connaissiez un petit peu vous nous
auriez pas un n'a pas été très bien donc
donc ça n'a pas été votre évolution mais
non moi je m'en fiche on vous êtes venus